this is me and this is my mother there
are nearly forty years between us I'd
like to be like her when I get old
an 81 year old who's full of beans I
could come over here every day and do my
gymnastics in the park people in Germany
are getting older and as long as their
health holds out they continue to be
active as they age how old do you feel
oh that's a tough question I usually ask
people how old they think I am but how
old do I feel I'd say mid-60s or so
certainly not as old as I really am
thank goodness it's your life motto my
motto in life is to try to not come to a
standstill to stay active continue to
look for and experience new things when
you come across something new don't
think oh you don't need to try that it's
not worth it at your age but just give
it a go
that attitude makes people like my
mother attractive for many companies
these so-called youthful seniors want to
lead independent lives and that means
they're an important part of consumer
society and they're not averse to modern
technology do you see how the colors are
changing that happens a lot on the
Internet when you swipe over something
with the mouse and the color changes
then you know you can click on it it's
like a button you can push okay but it's
not doing anything why isn't it reacting
my mother's generally unfazed even when
things get complicated it's been
seamless I'm pretty persistent once I've
started something and feel I need to
learn how to do it then I stick with it
until I can even if it's difficult and I
have to swear it myself a little I say
biggie don't be stupid
just keep on trying only say my voice
and give myself a little pep talk and
that usually works
just clap munch my what are my lessons
my mother taking trips is a way of
staying active in old age travel loving
seniors have become a lucrative market
for tour operators special travel clubs
offer package tours for them if my
mother's happy to spend her money on
that and make her remaining years
Pleasant I don't spend much time
dwelling on the future who knows what
might happen in a week or in six months
I try not to think about that too much I
don't feel old and I hope that's the way
it stays for a while living in the here
and now I think that's a good attitude
to have at any age